Oh Billy Eilish has arrived at the
Grammys how you feeling I'm feeling a
lot of things well you know a lot of
things first I'm gonna ask you about
something that's just at the top of all
of our minds and I saw you instagrammed
about it Koby how did you hear what was
your reaction how are you feeling right
now I mean I don't know how to put it I
I thought it was fake because how can
you not it really makes you think about
how a lot of things I don't know it's
really hard to talk about it's so sudden
and so random and like his beautiful
girl and like I I have no words
my condolences I don't know what to say
it's unbelievable I think our stomachs
dropped we're all shocked and all we can
do is try to remember him tonight I know
they're putting together a tribute we
also want to celebrate the incredible
work of tonight all these musicians who
have worked so hard and I mean it's your
first Grammy stand you have six
nominations is that insane to you are
you talking about I'm ready to lose all
of them you haven't even thought about
the speech what do you mean you're gonna
win girl I'm not but thank you have you
considered what you will say I don't
think but I'm hopeful I'm hopeful I mean
have you talked to that unbelievable so
deserved have you talked to anybody else
in your categories or have you heard
from your boy Justin Bieber on this
Grammys day honestly so much love for
all the other nominees and like every
other artist in every category like I'm
just excited I think it's gonna be fun
was this surreal for you waking up this
morning and how do you think you're
gonna feel if you hear your name called
it's so stressful but I don't know it's
like it's like the craziest thing in the
world so I'm so grateful to be here
forever well you want to talk crazy
let's talk youngest person ever to be
doing a James Bond theme what can you
tease for us about what that song is
gonna be what can I teach I don't know
if I got anything for you you kind of
just gotta wait it's it just is what it
is and it's good I also got to ask you
about your claws can we hold these up
claws out I mean I mean what vibe are
you giving us right now Billy a girl
that's not to you to decide what can I
do a fashion fill-in-the-blank with you
we're doing this up okay three hours ago
I was only wearing this I was wearing
just like some black okay the secret to
my look is the most random thing I have
with me is I have lollipops in my pocket
lollipops just for that energy and my
trick to getting here in this outfit
looking perfect was I just had to not
think too hard if I think too hard I get
all up in my head so don't overthink it
youngest person ever with 4 nominations
in the major categories Billy what was
the most emotional moment you had
realizing all this experiencing this
moment I think the sooner it's gotten to
the Grammys it's like more intense like
I didn't really process it until like
yesterday and yesterday I was like
like this is real life like Durham so
it's been last minute because I kind of
again like if I think too hard I'm go
off and be crazy so yeah and family
losing it for you over there yes of
course they're all here okay we can't
wait for the bond song one word to
describe
[Music]
find out okay it's gonna be fine I mean
tell us about these shoes you a
bejeweled boo oh I'm green cuz I'm just
killing it and you can all be green with
them we have a um sure
[Music]